حسنًا ، ليس لدي أي صفحات هنا
وأنا تسع صفحات ، أي فيليسيا ،
نحن جيدون يمكننا موسيقى الروك أند رول
[موسيقى]
كما تعلمون ، أصبحت ناشفيل
عاصمة العازبة في العالم
كنا خارجين في فيجاس سافانا
الجميع في كل مكان أكون آمنًا
لأقوله إن ناشفيل لديها ما يقرب من ثلاث إلى
أربعمائة حفلة عازبة هنا كل
عطلة نهاية أسبوع كل يوم جمعة وسبت
كانت مليئة
برحلات فتيات حفلات
توديع العزوبية  في أمريكا ،
هناك الكثير من
وجهات الحفلات الأخرى التي تركز على مثل
تجربة كبار الشخصيات أو نوع من
التفرد ، فهي تركز حقًا على
الانفتاح وقضاء وقت
ممتع مع أي شخص آخر حول
[الموسيقى
] تأتي شركات الخزنة لدينا
وجبات خفيفة لدينا  الشمبانيا نريدك حقًا
أن تشعر أنك تعرف أنك مرتاح
ومريح قدر الإمكان في مساحتنا
، فكلها جميلة ، إنها ليست
كالعادة بالقرب من الشمس حيث ربما تذهب أبدًا
ستة أسابيع بالنسبة لموظفينا المنتظمين ، يتواجدون
هنا كل 3-4 أيام أو الأشخاص الوحيدون
الذين يغسلون شعرهم ، إنها مساحة
للحضور وتشعر وكأنك سيدة
[موسيقى]
سعيدة لوجودها هنا وأحدث بعض الضوضاء
اسمي  هو هيث ، أنا مساعدك في
البار ، وسأكون دي جي الخاص بك ، وسأكون صديقك المفضل الجديد ،
وسأكون موعد الزفاف ،
وسأتصل بخطيبك ، لدينا مجموعات
قادمة من جميع أنحاء المكان الذي
عملنا معه  المجموعات الدولية
الكثير من المجموعات من كندا ،
كان لدينا مجموعتان من أستراليا هذا
الصيف لدينا في جميع أنحاء العالم
الدنمارك كوجهة تجارية في البرازيل
الآن للحفلات المخضرمة
لأنها مدينة ودودة وتشعر
حقًا أنك محلي  شاهد موسيقيًا مشهورًا
يسير في
Publix بجوارك أثناء انتقاء
مشترياتك من البقالة ويعتقد الناس من مدن أخرى
أن هذا رائع
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
جلبتني الموسيقى إلى هنا ثم
نوع من بارجة الحفلة  تولى الأمر
ورأينا حفلات توديع العزوبية
قادمة  لقد رأينا الحاجة إلى شيء من
هذا القبيل ،
لذلك قررنا إنشاء قارب على عجلات من
أجل السلامة ، فنحن نمنحهم بشكل أساسي
جولة مفصلة في وسط مدينة ناشفيل ، ونقوم
بعمل محطات توقف ، ويحصلون على خصومات في
الحانات الشريكة لدينا ، أفضل تجربة هي
أنها لأول مرة  إلى ناشفيل لأننا
نعرض عليهم مدينة بأكملها ، فهم
ينقلون الروح المعنوية إلى السكان المحليين ويلتقون ببعض
السكان المحليين هنا
في العام الأول الذي كنا فيه بالخارج ، قمنا بعمل
حوالي خمسمائة أو ستمائة
حفلة توديع العزوبية وكان ذلك ما يصل إلى ثلاثة
آلاف تقريبًا سنويًا وهذا ما يحدث
لقد نمت كثيرًا
وأصبحنا عاصمة العزوبية في العالم
[موسيقى]
أنت